[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
show we are honored to be with a very
special guest uh Grandmaster Yuri
Schulman yesterday at the opening
ceremony Yuri was inducted into the Hall
of Fame Yuri Welcome to our show it's so
good to see you we've played together on
world teams and US
championships how are you great yes or
no those were wonderful memories and and
I still remember your game against
shakar midar and you had like such a
wonderful example how you should come
back from retirement you know yes just
simply had super tournament there we're
here to talk about you stop I'm
preparing myself for the future time
when I'll get back to chess commentator
well first of all welcome to the show
seriously and I'm going to step off for
a couple of hours I'm going to be back
at the the end of the round it's all you
and Kate and chrisan congratulations
what a great achievement so my first
question is how does it feel to be
inducted into the US Chess Hall of Fame
no I my my biggest feeling is really to
enjoy time spending here like again seen
how wonderful is to be around great
chess players about uh like to to see uh
how the chess club in St Louis is not
only chess club anymore it's already not
even chess uh
like Square it just looks like Chess
Street right now so there so un chess
Avenue right so it's really amazing so
like I I really had this this was the
most Pleasant feeling just to see how
chess here is really part of the life in
uh St Louis and and uh I I heard that
like people even officially trying to
count how many Grand Masters yeah and
just it's like around 30 plus I
think just and maybe you're the new New
Edition right right exactly I am in fact
and as we uh do our us Championship
coverage honestly don't you miss it
absolutely yeah like it's probably
probably one of the reasons I stopped
playing chess it was just I couldn't
qualify for 2014 US championship and
though I had some great tournaments
before that but uh it was already such a
challenging thing to qualify and the
motivation was gone and and again yes
sir only your example might
help challenges of the day what are you
doing what are you doing you have a new
chess program chess Without Borders tell
us about it right right yeah like um I
mean it's not a new program yeah like uh
we started in 200 U maybe five I think
yeah and
um yeah we have around probably 400
students in Chicago area uh some of them
are really getting strong and uh uh
finally I'm happy to see that our
students are getting better and
participate in strong tournaments and
let's go to a shot from last night's uh
ceremony where we get to uh list some of
your outstanding accomplishments and uh
the
induction uh and by the way I thought
your speech was really good oh thank you
yeah I think we have some some view roll
of
it actually it's just your
photo and you're getting closer and
closer this is your match uh with
Gregory
kaidanov uh photos of you Alexander uh
Lenderman Alex Lenderman uh from the
2012 pardon me I remember very young
looking uh the way didn't did you come
through the Texas program or did you do
things at the
univers um 2000 yeah like yeah that's
that's how I came uh at that time I met
U Katy Stone and Nan Zion and
like one of the I think it's National
open or Us open in Las Vegas and they
invited me and then team Redmond of
course and that was how I think chess
and UT doas started to grow and then
UMBC and uh lots of schools after that
they really like started uh getting
stronger and stronger teams as well I
really liked it that we we we set the
challenge to other schools like to get
some Grand Masters yeah and now maybe I
wouldn't we were thinking today like
maybe I wouldn't even make to one any of
those teams but at that time qualifi and
you were talking about your
accomplishments you like US champion but
you also we very important uh you were
part of the Women's National Team you
were our coach for two big events we
almost medaled at the Olympiad and we
did really well at the world women's
Team Championship you said you missed
playing do you missed coaching on this
absolutely yeah like it was fun time I
know Kine I was helping probably little
bit more in Norway to you than in China
but I think you know still it was those
were wonderful memories when we were um
I was helping to the ladies team and
also to the men's team at some point but
do you have any memories from coaching
the women's team or the men's team or
even some funny memories from the US
championships you wish to share uh from
the US Championship um no I mean
yesterday I mentioned like uh like how
me kerina and Wesley went to that's
really s you had to see it I I cannot
like repeat
myself yeah the Arctic Ocean yeah could
be could be
challenging well the idea there was you
were mentioning that Wesley jumped in
the water and the he he violated the
rules of physics as he jumped out of the
water faster than he jumped into it me
and Kina are trying to get in very
slowly very and Wesley said something is
not right there and uh yeah no I I can
say like his chess approach is much more
professional jump to the wall Christian
jump in with a very very special guest
well first of all congratulations big
congratulations that's a big step in
your career your coaching career your
career as a grandmas as a chess player
and a player that has been involved in
the Chess World for so many years right
so congratulations uh Yuri tell us a bit
about this tournament You've Won it once
what do you need as attributes as a
chess player to win oh some somehow I I
I used to love to play this man even you
know not necessarily it was just in uh
St Louis but also when the tournaments
were on in San Diego in uh Oklahoma yeah
so so but um uh somehow yeah I enjoyed
it so much like when you come it was
celebration uh to play Such just
tournaments right yeah and uh what does
it take to win is to probably
um there is some luck to it of course
but um you definitely want to enjoy the
event and um that's what I definitely um
uh like was feeling at uh your
championships I always was enjoying like
feeling uh having great schedule also
and uh meeting my friends it was really
nice yeah like going for a walk and not
playing like two rounds a day and eating
some unhealthy food so here here it was
totally like different experience you
enjoy it yeah you have your schedule and
you analyze games after so just uh it
was great yeah Yuri thank you so much
for joining us it's a great pleasure to
see
don't be a stranger much success on your
chess program chess Without Borders
thank you thank all your coaching and
you also were asking what uh what else I
was up to I'm teaching also I don't know
if like how to PL as our 2-year-old you
know he's like still maybe his his way
of moving pieces is a little different
that we get used to but uh still you
know hopefully he'll enjoy it also our
son Mark you know so he'll also join our
one of our chess programs once again
congratulations really great achievement
thank you for being here with us thank
you very much for absolutely once again
and everybody to remind you of our
pairings let's just take a refresher as
we are in round